Doug Jones victory was a setback for
President Trump who supported more after
backing senator Luther Strange during
the Republican primary the president
tweeted this this morning I said Roy
Moore will not be able to win the
general election I was right a new
razor-thin GOP majority in the Senate 51
to 49 will make it even harder for
Congress to pass mr. Trump's agenda next
year Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
with reaction to this historic vote
Nancy good morning good morning well
most immediately losing that seat is
going to put more pressure on
Republicans to pass their tax cut plan
in the next couple of weeks before their
majority shrinks and the finger-pointing
has already begun listen to this Senate
Leader Mitch McConnell's super PAC
released a statement overnight saying
not only did Steve Bannon cost us a
critical Senate seat in one of the most
Republican states in the country but he
also dragged the President of the United
States into his Fiasco Senate
Republicans are now going to have an
even tougher time passing GOP priorities
like cutting entitlements or building a
border wall because they'll now only be
able to afford one GOP defection on many
votes and that means that moderate
Republicans like bob corker and john
mccain and susan collins are waking up
this morning with even more clout now
despite all of this there is some relief
among Republicans that they aren't going
to be getting saddled with Moore's
baggage Arizona's Jeff Flake put it
short and sweet last night
decency wins but the bottom line here
Yael is that Republicans who were
already frustrated that the Senate can't
seem to pass the president's priorities
are about to get even more frustrated
that is the other part of this story
thank you very much Nancy